c'est une initiative dans le cadre du
plan de relance du gouvernement la
tournée de l'apprentissage orchestrée
par le ministère du travail s'est arrêté
à maurepas
objectif permettre aux jeunes de se
familiariser avec l'apprentissage
les jeunes n'ont pas forcément
connaissance de tous les avantages de
l'apprentissage voie surtout les
inconvénients difficulté ce n'est pas
négligeable que de trouver effectivement
le contrat d'apprentissage c'est à dire
l'entreprise qui va les embaucher c'est
aussi la méconnaissance de tous les
domaines vers lesquels ils peuvent se
tourner en voie professionnelle du ceap
et au masters sur des formations qui les
entoure ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on va voir le métier de prévoir si ça
nous plaît et pouvoir éventuellement
continuer ou changer un petit peu de
voix en cours de route donc c'est
vraiment le principal atout de
l'apprentissage aux découvertes des
métiers et des formations pour l'année
prochaine six jeunes du centre
d'éducation et de formation
professionnelle de villepreux ont
participé à ce rendez vous ils sont tous
en dernière année de ses api et prépare
la suite de leurs études
là on a donné des informations sur la
voiture est donc fausse peut y aller
pour pour m'inscrire
renseigner et du coup c'est intéressant
pour l'année prochaine faut réfléchir
tu apprends toujours des choses toujours
entre steet apprendre des choses et ça
fait du bien pour le cerveau je souhaite
continuer mes études j'ai fait une
formation en informatique
bien sûr si j'en trouve je trouve que
c'est un métier indispensable de nos
jours vu l'évolution de la technologie
sort la tournée de l'apprentissage reste
en ile-de-france ce prochaine étape du 3
au 7 novembre 2020 dans le département
du val de marne